the first thing I wanted to mention is I
believe you and I are the same age uh
born the same year 63 6 I'm 77. okay now
I was born in 1963. yeah me too so we're
both the same age and you guys are
headed out on a tour uh the M72 tour and
you guys are leaving this is going to
come out pretty soon this tour you've
got this this new album 72 seasons and
I've been listening to this one tracks
at this one track Lux at Turner on it
which
doesn't just track and I'm thinking
these guys have not lost a step well
thank you no but I mean this could have
been 1981.
it's stunning to me you you guys uh you
know what you're doing you know exactly
what you're doing and uh here it is all
these years later you're headed out on
this massive year this massive tour
that's going to last two years if
someone told me I was going out for two
weeks on a tour right now I would find
the nearest chair and beat them with it
run over to Jack's house yeah yes yeah I
would hide under all his CDs I don't
know how how do you I mean at this point
in your life the physicality the amount
of determination it takes uh it's it
just blows my mind
the easy answer is that it doesn't get
any easier whatsoever and and I as I've
been explaining this in the last week or
two as I've started hearing myself do
interviews again about this around this
new project it it takes
twice the effort or more just to reach
the same level just to Plateau so it's
not you know I'm on the Peloton an hour
and a half a day and I'm working out and
I'm watching what I'm eating and I'm
being healthy and all that to get better
it's just to stay the same at this age
but um you know I take it seriously all
of us in our own ways take it seriously
all of us have different routines on
unique ways of approaching it and the
main thing is that when we get up on
that stage we want to be there for the
other guys in the band and obviously for
the audience and and be the best we can
be I do find myself uh
often at a sort of Crossroads in my mind
where it's like I I eat the same
for breakfast every day I eat the same
for lunch every day I more or less
the same thing for dinner every day I'm
very very routine based and I really
like to be in that routine but as soon
as I'm out of that routine it's like
I Need My Tofu for dinner and I need my
protein and I need this and that and
then I kind of sit there and go really
you can't just go to a restaurant with
your friends and have like what's on the
menu you gotta be that rigid so so there
is that that kind of rigid thing that
you really feel that that's how you get
to the place where you can be your best
every day at those shows
the other side of that if you could sit
here with your 22 year old and go really
that's what you've become so it's sort
of it's like it's a constant it's a
constant battle between those two
approaches but somebody said a couple
weeks ago when I was explaining these
new lifestyle choices as we call them he
said um uh you know it sounds like you
you you if it feels good to feel good
yeah and I like that I I still
occasionally drink it but it's like it's
like once a month now and I eat my
protein and my yogurt and my egg whites
and My Tofu you know you're describing
the rock and roll dream that's right you
know
people want to keep doing this there are
so many kids
there's so many kids since like 1981
that'd be like I I want to be James
Hetfield I want to be Lars Ulrich you
know that's my dream and uh to find out
later on that it's well okay tell
everyone egg whites nine hours of sleep
a night hydrate avoid the sun
um check your stool every day to make
sure there's no corn in there
um just
this is but you know it's the way life
goes this is the way girls you know the
best this is a my favorite analogy uh my
favorite analogy for life and aging and
it's not funny but it's very profound
and it's something that I think about a
lot is that when you're born you're
dropped into a fast current and so you
don't even have to do anything and you
just start growing taller you start
getting muscle you start you know
everything and and then the current
starts to slow down in your late 20s
early 30s and then 40 and then the
current kind of stands still so in order
to make any progress you need to kind of
but then the current starts moving
against you so that in order to just
stay in the same place you need to start
doing butterfly strokes and working hard
and what you're describing makes sense
which is
um what we were just doing in uh
Norway shooting uh this this TV project
I had to I did the same thing as you
yeah I was my weight and I was working
out I was I was eating right and
everything just so I could run around
and be the jackass that I was 25 years
exactly yeah uh doing nothing and and
you know what uh I mean as as easy it is
to make fun of and we can sit here and
blah blah blah but I I like when I'm up
on stage and I feel strong and I'm in
that moment and the four of us are
connecting and we're connecting with an
audience whatever the size is all of
it's worth it yeah all of it's worth it
and I do actually
um I'm 20 pounds lighter now than I was
at the peak or the bottom however you
look at it of the pandemic and I
actually feel good and you know
proactive and we get done and we
move forward and it's it's kind of
cool and it's not you can't do what you
do you cannot do those shows and and you
just cannot do it I mean I to think
about what it takes you know the caloric
burn but also the concentration it's
also the mental element of it if you
feel good
like the analogy for instance with
alcohol is that if I have a couple
glasses of wine a couple glasses of
champagne it's not really going to
affect the show the next day but a
couple of glasses of wine will affect my
sleep because then I gotta go up and go
to the bathroom two three times or
whatever and then the Sleep effects the
mood the next day and then the mood and
the sleep and all that then affects
the two and a half hours on stage so
there's a domino effect at play here
that you have to be respectful to but
listen
um who would have thought that you know
coming up on 41 years later that
Metallica would still be functioning
would still be
relevant enough to be you know sitting
here with you guys thank you very much
still welcome you know uh you know going
out going out there and playing um you
know
going out there and playing a two-year
tour and and putting records out that
still uh connect with people and you
know even in the wake of something like
strangers things last summer I know that
was crazy reaching more and more people
who the would have thought that
40 years ago or even if even if we were
sitting even if we were sitting 20 years
ago and going
in 23 you know the biggest rock bands in
the world would be the chili peppers and
guns and roses and AC DC and Metallica
or whatever you would be going no
there'll be a whole new younger
generation coming in and dethroning
everybody you know who was big 20 years
ago and we'll all be you know in
retirement homes somewhere and we're
still out here doing it and guns are
still out here doing it and AC DC is out
here and so on and so forth that's a
crazy thing and who would again thought
you know if you take it a step further
and say you know McCartney just turned
80. he's still out there yeah jackers
doing all those sexy bum Wiggles better
than he's ever done and connected but I
mean he's doing it against his own he
can't stop you know now it's involuntary
nobody
was always that way it's a spasm it's
but I mean it's it's certainly uh it's
inspiring and I think that as long as
the shoulders and the necks and their
knees and the backs and all of if they
keep functioning on the four uh
Metallica guys we'll keep doing this
hopefully for another 20 years egg
whites and tofu included